hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world
Ukraine vs russia is a bomber now being
dragged into the conflict the most
anticipated local election america is
approaching and there'll be no howdy
partner for this sheriff in Wyoming
President Obama is facing rising
pressure to provide Ukraine with
military aid in its battle with Moscow
backed rebels but how far should the
president go and could this lead to
another proxy war involving Russia and
the United States well as usual the
Democrat commentator Geoffrey Robinson
is in New York conservative commentator
Armstrong Williams is standing by for us
in Washington Jeffrey would you favor
further engagement well I would favor
first of all an exit strategy that's the
first thing and the most important thing
that the State Department Congress and
the president will have to decide on
that if we go in how do we get out what
will Putin's reaction be this is very
very thin ice and it's going to take an
awful lot of thought before we do
anything what would you do I'm stopped
well listen um we have no choice
actually but to support your crane ians
in this conflict the problem is if this
is something that it should have taken
place long ago it's like a
johnny-come-lately I don't even know you
know we thought the Cold War was a
devastating point in our history I'm not
I can't even make the argument that
Putin would not be willing to drop
nuclear arms on Crimea I just think that
we've not seen anything like this in a
long time Putin is it is in a very
dangerous state right now and the
problem is he has no respect for our
president he Trump's him and every cause
he feels he can do whatever he wants to
do I don't know if the lone superpower
in the world that be in the United
States as enough the stop Putin for
March
in crime era I totally ignore whatever
the United States tries to do in terms
of helping Ukraine that he plays this
one upmanship I just think it's a very
dangerous and tenuous situation well
let's now cross to Kiev the capital of
Ukraine one of the main decision makers
there the political director of the
foreign ministry is elective mikhay off
Alexei Mikhail thank you for being part
of our program today what would the
Ukrainian government such as it is in
Kiev have America do we need at least
three things first what we need is to be
united for Ukraine for the whole
Democratic world we what would like to
have United States UK the whole European
Union all other partners of your grave
bro to stay united and to support
Ukraine to support Ukraine then by
military technical needs to support
Ukraine in a framework of international
organizations and of course to support
Ukraine in bilateral talks which United
States UK the European Union have with
Russian Federation because what we are
witnessing right now in Ukraine is not a
danger of a cold war it's not a danger
of a year third world work what we are
witnessing now is the war against
Ukraine the war against our territorial
integrity our sovereignty and we are
fighting right now for our freedom and I
think this is my message to everybody in
United States and in the UK that the
people which fights for its freedom and
independence against nuclear power which
doesnt abide by international principles
and commitments anymore this country
should be supported it's all very well
you calling for Europeans Americans and
everything else to do the talking for
you have you tried talking to the
Russian
yourself absolutely we're trying to talk
to them bilaterally we talked to russian
federation in a framework of different
formats so called Normandy format with
participation of the unit of germany and
france ukraine and russian federation
the resale called geneva format with
participation of the United States and
the European Union but it is Russians
what do they want well they tell us that
they are absolutely out of the conflict
they are not a part of the problem they
do not recognize the presence of the
armed force here in eastern Ukraine in
Donbass they are not ready to cooperate
with us and with the international
community in the framework of
international organizations and it
looked like they don't want the conflict
to be solved let's bring in the others
if I may Jeffrey this is all happening a
very long way for the United States of
America why should Americans care that's
a very good question i suspect they
don't morally yes I think the world
supports Ukraine I don't think there's
any doubt about that if it were a
question of bilateral talks I think the
US would be happy to sit down but the
minute you start talking about weapons
you bring Putin into this in a way that
we may not want him coming in and the
Ukrainians may want him may not want him
coming in and I and I would like to ask
mr. my Kiev you know you've got you've
got Putin on one side you've got the
Ukraine which is politically well let me
put it this way there are corruption
problems in the Ukraine why should
America take a risk especially if you
lose I mean what's its what is the
benefit for America except moral support
of democracy I agree with that but what
happens if you guys we give you arms and
then you lose where are we well I think
democracy is what everybody in America
years about right and the same goes to
to freedom you ask me why should America
care because actually hear the Russian
Federation is trying to destroy the
neighboring country the Russian
Federation is trying to destroy all the
international commitments and the system
of international law which emerged after
the World War two so just if we imagine
that the Russian Federation succeeds who
will be the next but I want to come back
to your central question now why the
United States should care and I think
the answer is very simple not even
complicated I don't I don't think we're
willing to admit this it is an all-out
war between the Russians and Ukraine it
is like a world war two people are dying
people being mutilated infrastructures
that are being destroyed whether the
media wants to play Patsy and not show
the images I mean America's role into
society whether we like it or not as a
superpower the step in where we see this
destruction of democracy this
destruction of human life the role is
the savior lives not about whether we
going to gain some kind of Alliance of
some kind of edge of being on the
forefront of fighting with Ukraine if we
have a humanitarian responsibility along
with the Europeans and the rest of the
peat world who would believe in decency
who cannot allow Russia to declare war
and expand this war more than what it is
right now this is our out war whether we
want to admit that's what it is not and
it's only going to get worse we need to
stop this baby before it becomes four
grown because it is eventually become
full grown and I don't think Putin will
stop at anything unless he understands
that we're serious an election Micaiah
does that mean you welcome Russian
forces or NATO forces in the form of
soldiers and armaments to come and fight
on your territory well we are not
talking about inviting me to into our
territory what we're striving for is
political pressure at this moment
political pressure on Russian Federation
to let them withdraw their forces from
from Ukraine and continue this this
discussion well I absolutely agree that
you may think that Russian Federation
would never enter the the Western Europe
and go with aggressive steps against
Western European countries that what
we've been thinking on one year ago we
never thought that our strategic partner
that our neighbor will annexed part of
our territory in Game one with their
soldiers to our charity there are parts
now of Ukraine Kiev maybe still
functioning but the reports in this
eastern area around the nets and in the
communities around there where life is
just ground to a halt isn't it health
care is stopped systems have stopped
schooling is stopped yeah that's true
that's the situation over over there on
in territory which are now controlled by
Russia Becht terrorists there is no
normal life and in comparison to that
all the territories that were liberated
from from those terrorists are living a
quiet normal life over there where the
excess to to medicine would excess for
the international community are 18
supplies we can manage the situation on
the territories which is controlled by
our government but those guys over there
they don't want to have a normal life
they are real terrorists they are
supported by Russian Federation and just
imagine over 400 kilometers of the
ukrainian-russian border is not
controlled and every day we witness new
armaments new weaponry new tanks coming
to to power territory and then our
cities like Mario ball two weeks ago are
shelled by Russian troops and Russia
Becht terrorists so we have civilian
losses only the shelling of Mario have
brought 31 civilian
death and more than 100 wounded and
every day the losses count more than
five our soldiers and numerous civili
lives what we need at this moment we
need to speak to those agreement russian
federation signed these are the
so-called Minsk arrangement there is a
good document and if Russian Federation
would be willing would be urged to
implement this arrangement in two or
three weeks we can solve the conflict so
okay I'm diplomat and we would like the
diplomatic solution to that and that's
why positive note will have to wrap up
our conversation today Alex Alexi
Makarov thank you very much it's two
months since the American town of
Ferguson was ransacked during rioting
and looting this after a jury decided
not to bring charges over the killing by
a policeman of a black teenager well now
it's two months ahead of the most
anticipated local election in America by
all accounts patricia bynes is the most
active political campaigner in Ferguson
Township she's a leading member of the
Democratic Party there patricia have you
got people engaged have you whatever
their political persuasion are they
going to show up and join the discussion
leading up to this election I absolutely
think so there are three contested
Ferguson city council seats on the
ballot and I think in light of
everything that has happened and as much
as we've talked about change I think
that the people of Ferguson are going to
answer the call because this is
certainly a defining moment for Ferguson
but also the st. Louis County region and
it's going to be a chance to show the
world it can Ferguson pivot toward
change or is it going to continue to do
the same thing why is it do you think
that african-americans haven't come to
the fore and said I want to serve this
city as a counselor before now um I
think this was a
call because I always believe that
people want to do the right thing when
they are confronted with these types of
circumstances so I think this was a
wake-up call and one of the candidates
that I'm already supporting inboard one
Ellen Jones she had told me over a year
ago that she planned on running so
everybody in the race is not someone who
decided to run on August ninth I'm
supporting candidates who have been
engaged in the community and have been
wanting to make this move even prior to
the Mike Brown situation Armstrong
Williams in Washington you see the
democratic process at this may be
terribly simplistic but unless people
are prepared to engage to actually say
yeah I'll have a go stand for me I'll
serve on the City Council unless people
are prepared to do that then things can
go wrong well you know you you have to
come in miss Bynes for her leadership
and her courage you know I'm just
curious I know this is such a challenge
how do you change a mindset that has
been so pervasive for so long to make
them understand what is that state what
can happen if you're not elected to
office you not have a voice on the
council as a mayor to make a difference
where you have real power it seems as
though one of the early challenges that
you may have had that may have changed
by now so you can update it is the fact
of people who have registered vote
versus those who have been certified by
the registrants office just how do you
make sure that people when they do
decide the bridges to devote their
qualified they will be accepted as a
person that can vote to make a change in
this election and do they understand
what is that steak and what qualifies
them to qualify as a voter Patricia um
yes am i understanding we've not had an
issue in qualifying people as a voter
people just need to register to vote at
the right address you just bring your
correct credentials that are needed
there's there's there are no additional
steps required in Missouri that are out
of the way to register to vote of the
issue that does take place that is a
little confusing and and what people
don't do is when they
move get a different address move to a
many different municipality or even just
just move to a different ward they do
not update their voter registration for
their addresses so that's one of the
biggest things where people register to
vote but they're not registered often
out of the current address that they
live in due to moving around let me just
bring in Geoffrey Robinson on this
particular point here Geoffrey of course
it would be too simplistic to join up
the dots and say just because you have a
more representative City Council means
that some racial tensions that exist in
the territory can be sorted out
overnight but it's a step in the right
direction isn't it oh it absolutely is a
step in the right direction and Patricia
bynes is a hero I mean she really is go
Patricia you've got a lot of America
behind you and never give up I do worry
however what the other side is doing to
stop you because they're not going to
roll over easily and I I wonder about
the more subtle ways of voter
suppression what are you encountering
what kind of resistance are you getting
from the Republicans well for the April
elections they are nonpartisan races so
we don't have a much of an issue of a
party line race but because they have
been low partisan and the turnout has
been very low this is where a lot of the
Republicans tend to get into office but
they don't have to announce as
Republicans they just serve at the
municipal level so a lot of people are
the just wanting to concentrate on
voters who have just turned out who they
think are going to turn out but I'm
positive that this is going to be a much
larger election that Ferguson has ever
seen so there's this idea that people
aren't going to vote we're going to try
to keep it that way and they've just
want to target voters who just who they
know we're going to come out but this is
larger than voters who are normally
coming out in April sorry I'm strong you
order to come in yeah you know it's
interesting Patricia I don't know if you
aware of this but our television group
owns the CBS affiliate in st. Louis
so we have great steak yes we do we have
great steak in what happens in Ferguson
offices of great importance to us but I
mean if you could just share with with
the people watching and listening what
do you expect to happen let's just say
if everything goes the way you want it
to go all the people that you're
embracing and endorsing happens to win
what real change can they make in the
lives of people who have been feel
disempowered for such a long time and
have no reason to vote what is it they
can do to bring people back to the
ballot box and and make it more of a
participatory government where they
realize that their voice doesn't matter
going forward right the the first thing
that first we want to do is celebrate
because i think it's going to be a very
large victory just in being able to show
people yep if we do this and we start at
the very local level and do this change
can happen i am hoping that the next
thing that takes place is that we start
developing better voter habits don't
just vote in November we have to keep
this consistent you have to come out in
April in st. Louis County and for our
August primaries and in November
elections so we're going to have to
continue to beat a drum to develop
better voting habits the next after that
step I see that we're going to have to
have a serious conversation about it's
not just about black candidates let's
talk about quality of candidates because
like the saying says all skin folk and
kin folk and we need to stop looking at
the colored people skin and get down to
what are you standing for we have a lot
of rebuilding that needs to take place
in Ferguson we need to look at
developing a West Florissant like
business corridor district so that way
not only the wider part of Ferguson has
the business district we need to look at
development in the area we need to get
the school board and the City Council on
the same playing field and
because education certainly affects
property values and that's going to
attract people into the area so there's
a lot of work that needs to be done
policy wise in trying to rebuild
Ferguson and it's going to be a stable
and make a statement for other ministers
surrounding municipalities that they
need to do the same and Jeffrey if we
widen out the Ferguson incident to the
whole of the United States are the
lessons for other local authorities in
particular police forces in the way they
sort out who is actually on the streets
keeping cities safe and the way they
behave yes there are real lessons is
when you get voter turnout you get
results which is why the Republicans is
so big on voter suppression especially
among the black communities and young
people and older people when voter
turnout when the when the right people
come out to vote you get the right
results I'd like to ask patricia when
the when the prosecutor is up for
reelection how soon can you get rid of
him what a bum well there is a recall
that can take place and he just got a
real ected in November so he's in a
four-year seat so I we also need to
pivot to a conversation about police
accountability at the local level but
the injustice that we are facing in our
system is not just with law enforcement
it what it's what happens afterwards
with our prosecutors with our judges
after people start coming through our
justice system the police are not just
on the front line we need to have a
serious conversation about reform within
the justice process itself I'm strongest
needs momentum doesn't it I mean there
were too many conversations from talking
heads on TV saying this must never
happen again we're only months down the
track what sign of change are you saying
you know I respect what she's saying
because it's more than a black and white
issue and when she mentioned the courts
just now I mean it's shameful how low
income people are fleas for parking
tickets with fines where it's part of
the budget uh-uh-uh other municipality
of Ferguson and so people feel they're
being unfairly singled out some people
are even
free to get into cars they go to a
grocery store because they may have a
record and they're afraid if the if the
cop stopped them they'll land them in
jail so what she's touching upon on the
first surfaces are real issues that need
real reform the restorative trust and
faith in the people again Patricia as
you go forward just in the last few
weeks are you seeing this positivity
which you've got reflected back from
some other people in the town absolutely
I think one thing that needs to that is
going to happen to continue to get
people engaged because you can't vote
and walk away these decisions are taking
place beyond election day they're taking
place in the city council meetings
they're taking place when people are
appointed in boards and commissions and
so with having people who are really
rooted in the community that is going to
have and bring people out to engage in
these meetings where the real
conversations about policy where the
votes are taking place at the council
people need to get engaged are coming to
the city council meetings and once we
can develop that engagement that's how
you get the voice of a community it's
not just voting somebody in we had to
stay on top of them we have to hold them
accountable and we have to let them know
we see you we want to make sure that
you're working on our best interests
Patricia Pines thank you very much for
being with us today thank you
now finally for this week a deputy
sheriff in Wyoming's been told to ride
em cowboy into the sunset deputy gene
Bryson has retired after 40 years
because a new policy has banned him from
wearing cowboy hats and cowboy boots
while on duty Geoffrey Robinson this is
a shocking way to send this poor man
into his r into early retirement should
you be allowed to wear what the heck you
like while policing the town well yes
and no you have to understand the new
sheriff Steven Haskell is a 25-year
veteran and combat veteran of the US
Marine Corps so you know good for you
sergeant I thank you for your service
you're now the sheriff of Sublette
County and when you say no more cowboy
boots there's a pretty good reason for
it you're talking about trying to pursue
criminals by foot with icy conditions
they're not really the best shoe for
that and that's what he wants combat
boots as for cowboy hats ah here's where
the sheriff and I disagree cowboy hats
are part of the tradition and custom of
the west and police forces all over the
West wear cowboy hats you also have the
new york state troopers wear cowboy hats
the Connecticut State Police wear cowboy
hats and for him to come in and say no
more cowboy hats in a county where there
are more cowboy hats than people that
may be a tough sell do you agree with
Geoffrey about this uniform thing
totally disagree uniformity is so
important the badge the uniforms they
had weather if you look at smokey bear
their hands are the same of this
assurance in the south the hats are the
same when people look at law enforcement
they need to know they're dealing with
the office of the law you should not be
able to dress any way you want to incur
boy whose suits and cowboy hats and
boots any kind of suit design that you
won't know uniforms are part of the gig
and I don't think the sheriff of sooo
glad County is talking about uniforms
he's talking about the cowboy boots
which do present a difficulty and cowboy
hats now you want uniforms just give
everybody the same cowboy hat why not
it's part of the tradition of the west
and I don't see why he would take that
away
thank you both guys for wearing your
uniforms to see us today that's it for
this edition of the debate until next
time goodbye